what's up guys it's the cast of shazam i
am ask your angel
i'm zachary levi i was on my phone when
we started that
i'm jackson zach dylan larvin right
there
buzzfeed has very awesomely created a
which iconic dc superhero are you
quiz just say the word wink and we're
about to go through all of those
questions together
i'll answer them and i'll find out what
dc superhero we're gonna be
i wonder what mine will be
all right so which junk food is your one
true weakness there's donuts
chocolate chocolate and then another one
would be chips not to be confused with
chocolate chips yeah
and then and then french fries cookies
and ice of the creme i'm gonna go fries
i'm gonna go with fries as well i'll go
chocolate choose a not so superpower
the ability to forget anything the
ability to speak fluent dinosaur the
ability to turn wine into water
the ability to breathe fire but only in
ability to fly indoors
ability to mind read with consent i'm
going to fly indoors
wait what is this is this the thing that
we can actually do if you had to pick
the best of the worst
how about does that you're going to pick
what i did didn't you didn't yet would
you pick it up
i didn't know i mean you know just
really big buildings ability to breathe
fire but only
all right come on guys pick one come on
it's hard
you are required to go back in time i'm
not gonna do british
uh for a mission choose an unfortunate
historical occupation for your alternate
identity disguise
vomit collector food taster to taste for
poison plague barrier
execution cleaner rat catcher or leech
collector
vomit collector leech collector a vomit
you would want the collection
wow i chose collection choose a dc films
actor to be your superhero
sidekick is it gal gadot is it jason
mamoa is it amy adams is it robin wright
is it henry cavill isn't it i've been
writing to be funny i'm going
henry cavill cyborg shazam would be a
really fun
i'll just go with henry cavill because
that would be that would humble him that
would
humanize him i think finally choose a
punny name for your
newly formed team of disappointing
superheroes the tween titans the justice
league
the horrified squad the sarcastic
poor oh the complex men and the
guardians of penitentiary
i picked the justice league i said the
guardians of pageantry the horror fight
squad
[Music]
i got nightwing i got nightwing oh you
got shazam
i knew that i would get you there
because i knew that they they casted the
movie wrong
he's been trying to take me out you got
nightwing even though life has been
especially tough on you you've managed
to come out on the other end
stronger than before so go get them
bright knight
that's awesome
you're an all-around talented individual
who has
little weaknesses little meaning almost
non-existent
if any even though my hurls challenges
at you like meteor is the night sky
there's nothing you haven't and can't
overcome sure
you may not wear a red cape and blue
tights
because i wear a white cape and red
tights but you're nothing
less than super i felt like my horse's
goat
what's what's your sister you got shazam
despite your
tough outer shell you're a child at
heart who would go out of your way to
help others just say the word
you're shazam i'm shazam i'm shazam you
guys should get out of here
it's my show now change the billboards
all over the city
to this space
[Music]
you